[Music]
hi I'm Dylan and I'm Jacqueline Dylan's
mom and we recommend succession it's the
only show i'veseen I'm Chuck I don't
watch TV
I'm not TV watcher we watched like three
hours one time watch three hours I felt
like I was back in college it's great
it's a peek into the ultra-wealthy they
just have a lot more at stake seemingly
to them because of the money
it'll be very serious and all this stuff
is going on and then they drop jokes in
it that are super morbid as well like
ruining someone's life
cheating making fun of being poor season
finale was we were snow going to my
husband's ball game by going what are
y'all doing it's the season finale if
you haven't ever seen succession I
recommend that you get somebody that you
really want to snuggle up with and watch
it because it's very captivating and I
love to snuggle
[Music]